miss gray out there
miss gray
she was when i just came back in judge
i do not see her she might be around
them
i think she may have moved when they
were bringing the defendant and they
cleared the hallway
hmm
um
journey entering
[Music]
our good afternoon members of the jury
please be seated
i will call miss gray to the stand
resume
her testimony
have a seat we're going to resume your
testimony now
all right go ahead mr valentine's
miss great i'm
referring to the post that you uh
testified to uh
directed that in response to the
prosecutor's question
um
with regards to warren cataract
officially being told to leave
did you personally
at any point
tell her to leave prior to that
text message i do believe that at some
point i said if you're so unhappy then
why don't you leave yes
i don't recall
now
prior to that text
were you involved personally with
michael in contacting an attorney
to start legal proceedings and get them
out yes sir and what's the name of that
attorney uh stephen tartus and
did there come a period of time
approximately a month
where the father was in europe
and everything was stalled yes sir
who is the person
making all the decisions based on your
interactions with regards to lauren
cataract and her staying on the form
michael and the father is that what
you're asking me
yes when you say the father lauren's
mother what did lauren's father do
as far as
this situation
strike me i'll withdraw the question
control the question please okay
was it
lauren's father who negotiated
everything with michael to your
knowledge
let's just uh how did do you know that
fact were you present during the
negotiations no
okay
um
with regards to those uh
postings that
you you talked about
on cross
did you ever see michael barristone
break
down in response to what he saw on those
social media posts yes sir and can you
describe some of those instances to the
jury
he continued to
become more and more fearful
to unravel to be in panic sheer panic
to say
we were concerned or worried was is an
understatement
but as things escalated day by day
his
deterioration
increased
did he ever break down
and literally get into a fetal position
yes sir
you witnessed that yes sir
now
you were asked about a number of
pictures
at the stable area
after you fled the farmhouse with
michael and your child
you were living in that club room that
was depicted correct correct
and and that's a pretty
straight
thing that whole room
is surrounded by
ceilings
walls yes
the office is surrounded by
uh the same thing
wood
yes sir big heavy doors wooden doors
correct yes sir now did there come a
time when
you believed
that your private conversations were
being reported yes sir and when was that
um i would say when we had moved up
there um so the end of july going into
august was when we determined that was
happening and and
how did you make that determination um
lauren would text
and taunt michael over things that only
we had discussed
in private
things you discussed
in private in the club room club room
and office
the office where the safe is
yes sir
and
when lauren would post something on
social media
did she always keep it up or would she
delete it
a lot of times it would be deleted
some things were left up yes okay but
other things were in fact deleted
correct correct
and at times did you take or try to take
screenshots of those things
to document the exact words that were
being said yes sir
now
were you presence
on the four occasions that michael
barriston called 9-1-1
yes sir
on august 31st
when the police arrived
did you personally hear him say
objection
no mr malinkas
sustained
you were you were present for each time
he called 9-1-1 correct correct
and
i'm not asking you what was said but he
had a conversation
with the police on each occasion correct
absolutely yes did you personally see
him try to show them some of these posts
or
screen shots yes i did
and what was their reaction
they did not take it seriously
and
what effect if any did you observe
those interactions
have on michael barrasson
it made it all a lot worse
did it make it worse for you
yes absolutely
now
the prosecutor talked to you about
the type of person michael barrasson was
with regards to his business
specifically that
you know how he ran his business
you indicated and again correct me if
i'm wrong that you express concerns
with regards to how michael barrasson
was
conducting his day-to-day business
operations correct i did yeah
was
michael barrissone
in a
fragile state of mind
running the business at that time mr
melinkas
let me see outside more please for a
minute
it's great yes
before i ask you the next question
you said that michael farrison was in a
in a fetal position position did that
happen more than once
yes
how many times
it could be quite often
and was he depressed
yes sir
was he severely anxious
very much
at any point in time when you
saw him going through all of this did he
ever come angry
no
have you ever seen any violence
displayed by michael barrasson at any
point in your relationship with him no
sir no violence
he yells a lot sometimes correct correct
now
did those things those specific things
that you just described with regards to
his
reaction to these events
affect his ability
to run his business
yes very much
affected his ability to make decisions
at times
yeah that's mr balinkus
i'm not sure she's if you want to get
into specifics about it but
you know you're asking her to
opine on the defendant's state of mind
in that question so
the objections
sustained now
the prosecutor asked you the questions
with regards to michael's divorce from
his wife veer
and showed you a specific text message
to your knowledge
does michael have a good relationship
with his ex-wife
yes sir
so when he talked about having her to
pay
having to pay her 900 000
plus in that
text you believe he held any animosity
towards her based on that judge can we
be heard at cyborg i i apologize because
i know the jury is here but
all right questions being withdrawn by
mr balancas
now
[Music]
the prosecutor asked you questions about
george morris and the
safe sport band do you recall those i do
now
did lauren cataract
file a complaint against you
yes sir
and how did that turn up objection
what's the basis for the objection i
don't know what the relevance to the
outcome of any of cities and what what
is that knowledge of safe sport and it
relates to the testimony of mr morris
well i don't see it relevant
what the outcome of it was
or the nature of it
now
there's been testimony on direct
that you sent safe sport hundreds and
hundreds of pages correct
that's correct
did you have any uh
contact with them by way of email
at what time
at any point in time prior to the intent
i did
yeah
um
to your knowledge in your presence did
michael have any contact with say sport
by email
um well not safe support directly for
either of us we were talking to uh sonia
keane on email okay and again did you
sometimes draft the emails for michael
sometimes yes
so
i'm going to show you defense exhibit
1000b
and refer you specifically to number
274.
yes
[Music]
yes
it's great i'm going to show you
d1000b
and refer you to a specific email
on august 3rd
27th
number 274 and if you to read this whole
thing
okay to yourself yes
no to yourself
um
okay do you recall uh helping michael
draft that email
i do
judge i'd like to
introduce that and read that email at
this time
i would object
you want a copy that the court can see
uh
come up come up the side more
[Music]
thank you
you indicated on direct examination that
in july
of 2019
that the relationship with lauren
cataract was toxic unhealthy
did you
ever discuss personally with michael
barrasson
having cataract removed from the
property yes sir
and
you've already talked about
getting a lawyer involved correct
correct
prior to august
was lauren cataract's father in europe
yes sir
to your knowledge was he contacted
with regards to by who
again this with knowledge that's could
be based on hearsay if she contacted him
that's one thing
she's got to have a basis for her
knowledge
were you there when anyone
personally contacted the father yes sir
who contacted the father michael bearson
did he send objection judge
i didn't even hear the quest i didn't
hear the question yet so i can't rule on
it so let mr blinkist finish the
question and then i'll rule on it
what's your question
did
were any
of these postings sent to the father to
your personal knowledge
yes
now
you indicated that your father came up
in the beginning of august correct
correct
who asked him to come up
i think both michael and myself did
and why did you ask your father
because i was terrified
did anyone else come up
to the state stable when things started
to get
toxic
yes sir who
uh dr ruth cox
and when you say dr ruth
cox
is she a uh psychologist yes sir
and and that's the woman you said was
sleeping in front of her
horses uh stall
yes sir
now
after you
started living in the clubhouse with
michael barrasso
did things get worse
as far as
the social media
attacks a lot worse yes
and
isn't it the fact
that lauren cataract
would
come up late at night
with a flashlight
to taunt you
and the people in the stable area i'm
going to object to the continued use of
the word taunting and threatening
obviously
yeah i mean that's the witness hasn't
testified about that you can ask her
what she observed
herself from her own personal knowledge
but don't characterize it
did you observe lauren cataract
coming from the farmhouse area
up towards the stable area in the woods
turning your flashlight on and off
i think that was michael that saw that
all right we'll strike that answer then
if it's not the witness's answer she has
no personal knowledge of it it's hearsay
if it was told to her so members of the
jury please strike from your memory that
last answer you can't use it for any
purpose
miss great
with regards to the
social media posts
did lauren cataract use any of your
private
conversations with michael barrasso
and post them on social media
yes sir
you ask specific questions with regards
to your son and his relationship with
michael barrett
is michael barrasson
ever alone with your son you not being
there
no to my knowledge maybe in passing or
we were always together
yeah
did michael barrasson love your son very
much objection mr belinkus
this witness can't testify about the
defendant's state of mind
you can ask her about her relationship
but not
embarrassing mr barriston's feelings
about other people that's not proper
sustained directing your attention to
august 7th
now
dcpp comes to the farm correct for
stable area correct okay
you have a meeting with her in michael
barrasso's office correct correct
and there
she told you that there was an
allegation objection
it's what
what's that what's the basis of it
she can't testify to what somebody else
told her
don't make comments
dcpp correct correct
michael barrisson
continually opened the door
and came in the office while you were
talking correct correct
did dcpp
tell you who made the allegations
just answer yes or no no
did did she give you
any indication who may have
done it's the same question it's
different judge
you didn't give a name but an indication
you're just asking the same question a
different way
did she say anything with regards to who
made the allegation
she said it
that's hold on
this is hearsay
just answer yes or no
did the dcp
workers specifically tell you who made
the allegation just answer yesterday
as you sit here
today
are you afraid of lauren counteract
objection that's sustained
did robert goodwin
ever threaten you
no sir
did an incident happen on august 8th
objection
yeah yes how long ago state
it's
after the shooting
there was an interaction judge
between mr goodwin and the witness
yes
and your father
what's the
what's the relevance of that
when
you believe that
your private recordings were
being
the private conversations were being
recorded
did
you or michael do anything with your
knowledge
to try to address that and
address that situation and determine
what was going on yes sir what did you
do
um we hired
like a
private investigator type person that
did debugging
to come to the farm and go through our
office club room locker area to look for
recording devices
and
that's great then
yes um this is great you were asked
about uh dr cox coming to visit the farm
in those days of august 2019. yes sir
had she ever
wanted to sleep in the barn near the
horses before no
she had never been warned not to sleep
in the barn because it reflected poorly
on the business
i like wait i mean i don't think she
slept in the bar now
prior to this
judge if i could uh have a sidebar
i'm going to show the witness
you need a breakout room i'm sorry a
breakout room yes breakout room
and i'm gonna
show her s-171
peace
and i'm going to direct your attention
to line 5735
is that a text message from michael
barissone
to you on december 7th 2018
that's correct
and does that refresh your memory that
the defendant told you ruth gave me a
never-ending text about how she needs to
be near dd and how could i be so cruel
to not let her sleep in the barn that is
what that says
yes if i could also have permission to
show the witness what's been marked as
s-172
sure in the breakout room right in the
breakout yes
and i'm going to direct your attention
to line two zero four three
is that a text message between you and
ruth cox on december 4th 2018
yes
and is that your refresh your memory as
to whether or not the defendant had
advised dr cox no more sleeping on the
couch or floor in the club room
because it's an olympic facility not a
trailer park that's correct i object to
that it has nothing to do with the
stable
area judge the implication was that dr
cox was sleeping in the bar
because she was so frightened and
terrified and this clearly goes to show
that she had done that or wanted to do
that on prior occasions this has to do
with the club as judge
all right i get it i get it
i sustain the objection
move on mr schneiderlin you were asked a
number of questions about uh mr
garrison's
demeanor i guess
in july and august of 2019
yes
and i think you were asked a series of
questions by mr blinkist
whether he was depressed
seriously severely anxious
uh do you remember that line of
questioning
today yes um
would you say or would you agree
that the defendant had issues with
depression or anxiety before lauren
kanrak ever came to the farm
yes
and at times would he make statements to
you
indicating
the extent of that anxiety or depression
yes and that was before he even met her
correct no further questions
did the interaction
and what was going on with lauren
cataract exasperate those
conditions very much
were you afraid
based on
that decline
that michael barrasson was going to kill
himself
yes that crossed my mind for sure
as
late as when in relationship to the
shooting
the day before
nothing
oh you may step down
okay yes thank you all finished ms gray
thank you
all right mr shalhon call your next
witness
we'll call justin harden
justin justin harden
please remain standing for a minute
place your left hand on that bible mr
horton if you would please raise your
right hand and listen to my court clerk
and minister in oath do you swear in the
presence of almighty god that the
testimony gives to this court regarding
this matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth i do
please state your name and spell your
last name for the record justin hardin
h-a-r-d-i-n thank you all right have a
seat mr harden please keep your voice up
nice and loud we have jurors in the
first two rows in the gallery if you
don't understand a question please don't
answer it just indicate you're not sure
or you don't understand and i'll have
counsel rephrase
go ahead mr shellhorn thank you mr
hardin can you please introduce yourself
to the jury
justin hardin and how old are you 42
do you know michael verasan i do do you
see him here in court today i do would
you identify him by an article of
clothing as well uh blue and red tie
by identifying a defendant
where do you currently live mr harden in
wellington florida
can you tell the jury a little bit about
your
own professional experience and what you
do for a living i am a horse trainer and
competitor
and is there a specific discipline that
you currently train and compete in yes
what is that dressage can you tell the
jury in your own words basically what
dressage
um
dancing with horses
have you ever ridden any other
equestrian disciplines i have can you
tell the jury what those are or what
those were
western and
eventing
approximately how long have you been
training and competing in dressage
approximately 22 years
now i'd like to draw your attention back
mr mr schoenhorn something has come up i
need to address
so i know it's early in the afternoon
but i do have to address it my staff
just informed me so i'm just going to
take a quick five minute break
i said i was going to be quick
mr horton just step outside for one
moment please
i need to see council at
sidebar one mr velenkus
gets back
he's honest
please
all right mr horn you may have a seat uh
go ahead mr shelton thank you judge
i apologize if i already asked you this
question but i think i was halfway
through it uh but could you tell the
jury approximately when you first met
the defendant
in 2002
can you tell the jury how you first met
him
i was applying for a job at his farm
do you recall which farm that was
his farm in new jersey
what was the job that you were applying
for at that time
a intern
would say working student
what does that term generally mean to
you
it's a
um
it's an opportunity to learn more about
the horse business and gain experience
did you get that job i did
from approximately the time you got that
job in 2002 until
2019
did you continue a professional
relationship with the defender yes
did your role or job change with respect
to
the farm or working with them yes how
did it change
it evolved over time
in the summer of 2019 what was your
position
assistant trainer
now working uh
working there from approximately 2002 to
2019
did your
business relationship with the defendant
at some time become more of a friendship
yes
are you familiar with whether or not he
owns any other farms yes and can you
tell the jury where
that other farm or those other farms are
in loxahatchee florida
did you have an opportunity to work at
both of those farms during the course of
time you were associated with the
defendant yes
can you tell the jury the reason why the
defendant owned two farms
the winter season is a
important competition time for our sport
as well as the weather
and would it be fair to say that the
winter competition is down south
yes
now i'm going to ask you a few questions
about the nature of michael barissone's
businesses for example was it common for
him to board more than one horse at a
time yes
do you recall with respect to the new
jersey farm approximately how many
horses there were stalls or living
quarters for
for stalls there was 33
as well as
a area for young horses
and was it common for those stalls to be
more or less filled with horses
yes
now you indicated that when you
initially came to work for the defendant
you were working as a working student
yes
was it common for him to have working
students
associated with the farm during the time
you were there yes
what was the approximate number of
working students that may be working at
any given time
it would vary but i would say between
four and eight
are working students paid
generally no
what was their uh i guess compensation
or what did they receive as a result of
working at michael barrasson's farm
living quarters
and
opportunity to learn
with about the horses
can you tell the jury what a writing
clinic is
a riding clinic is
um usually a two or three day period of
time where
a clinician or teacher will
teach
basically for the whole day a series of
of riders and horses
generally the clinician would be from
out of town traveling
have you ever
been a clinician at a riding clinic i
have are you aware of whether michael
barrasson has ever been in clinician yes
he was would you say that he did that
with any frequency during the time that
you work for very much so
you had also indicated that you are a
competitor yes can you tell the jury a
little bit about what a horse
competition entails
our sport has a set time for your
competition and a predetermined routine
um that you are judged on
so you you get the routine in advance
yes and then do you practice that
specific routine with your horse yes
are those events held at the farm or
barn where you're training or somewhere
else somewhere else how do the horses
and the riders get to
the
location where the event
is um
owners either have their own own their
own transportation or they will have
them shipped there commercially
did the defendant or was the defendant
ever involved with transporting horses
uh
for horses that were training at his
farm to various events yes and would
that be something that the owner would
pay extra for or would it be included in
the price of boarding and training in
general trailering was extra
now with respect to the new jersey farm
uh at any time when you were working
there where did you live
on the farm
and i'm gonna show you uh judge if i
could
pull up s 391
which is already in evidence sure
and mr harden that's uh what's been
marked in evidence as s 391 what do you
recognize that to be
that would be the new jersey farm
can you indicate for the jury on this uh
map
the approximate area where the
farm house is located that you indicated
you lived in
oh yeah i'm sorry
they won't be able to see where you're
pointing um there should be a pointer
next to you and we can try that
we'll see if it works it might not work
with this
i don't think so
okay
well can you describe the area the jury
has already seen this so i think they'll
know where you're talking about okay uh
near the top left of the picture
um
there is visible the roof of a farmhouse
and can you describe that farmhouse how
many levels is it
two levels and a basement
did you live on various uh locations or
in various levels of that farmhouse over
time yes where did you live when you
began living there in the basement did
anyone else live in the basement yes who
else lived in the basement other uh
assistants working there at the time and
what was the general layout of the
basement at that time
uh several bedrooms and a common living
area
over time as your roles and your role
and responsibilities at the farm changed
did you move to another location in the
farmhouse i did where was that on the
top floor of the farmhouse
and what was the general layout or set
up there
it was a two-bedroom
apartment was the living room in the
kitchen
do you recall approximately
for how long you lived in that apartment
until
the spring of 2019.
do you recall when you may have moved up
there initially
approximately 2004.
so you have lived there for
a number of years yes
now with respect to s 391 uh is it fair
to say that the
that's the driveway going down the
middle of the the
diagram next to the farmhouse yes and in
the bottom right hand corner
can you describe and if it's easier for
you i'm sure the judge would allow you
to come down and point it out for the
jury if you could just describe
what some of those facilities are in
that bottom right hand corner
it's the main stables
where the horses were kept and the
indoor and outdoor riding arena
also on the very bottom right are the
paddocks and the round pen
and what's the
significance of the paddocks and the
round pen it's where the horses would
spend their time outside some of the
there's others some of the
when they would spend their time outside
and the round pen was used for training
young horses
are the various fields and all maybe
i'll just start with it looks like there
are two green fields that are on both
sides of the driveway and then there's a
third green field
sort of on the right hand side of the
diagram there were those part of the
property yes
and what was
was there anything done with those
threes
they were used for farming hay for the
horses
is the driveway that goes down the
center of s391
flat
no
and do you can you describe that for the
jury
uh
from the street the first part of the
driveway is a pretty consistent incline
and then
flattens out
about a third of the way
so based on your familiarity with living
there for
15 years or so
if you were at the
stable facility in the bottom right
corner are you able to see
the farmhouse from there
no are you able to see any part of the
farmhouse to know from an orientation
standpoint where it is the very top of
the roof
and then the
i guess at the other side if you were at
the farmhouse are you able to see from
the farmhouse to where the stables and
barn are no
now you indicated that there were
there's a stable and there's also an
indoor arena as part of that big
building there yes what else was was
part of that big building
what else was in there
uh there was a clubhouse with a kitchen
and a common area
and also a workshop
what was the general
decor in the uh the clubhouse there
farm
country
were there anything uh or was there
anything hanging on the walls or
displayed uh with respect to some of the
accomplishments of other either michael
barrison or people that he had trained
yes
judge i'd like to show
the witness a number of pictures at this
point
one of these new or these in evidence
these are new photos your honor
s318
330.
all right mr blencus you've seen those
photos yes there's no objection
all right those uh photographs i think
it's 318 through 330 will be admitted
into evidence
they'd be displayed to the witness and
the jury
mr hardin the first uh photo that we
pulled up here is s-318
what is that a photo of
uh that would be the
center of the main stables
now i think you indicated one end of the
stable when we were just looking at the
aerial shot was connected to the end
with the club room and the indoor arena
yes what was that the other far end of
the stable
oh were there doors or anything else
there were doors on all ends of the
stable
so there was doors on all ends and
this door that we're looking at a
picture of an s318 where is this door
would have been a side door
approximately halfway down the structure
and if you were to go out that side door
in s 318 where would that bring you onto
the front
on to the outdoor arena
i'm going to
go to s3 19.
what is s319 a picture of
this would be the far end of the stables
farthest away from the indoor riding
arena
and from the location where this picture
is taken
what would be on the stables to the
outside to the left
the parking lot and what would be on the
outside of the stables to the right the
outdoor arena
and is this the
area where you indicated that you
thought there were stalls for
approximately 33 horses 25 25 thank you
uh s
320
is s3 what's s320 a picture of
this would be the other side of the
first picture that we saw
so this would be
a hallway looking out into the driveway
now that um entryway just after the
the hallway out to the outside what's
inside there a wash doll for washing the
horses
is this the opposite side
yes
that's s321 just for the record we'll
move on to s3
22.
is it fair to say that generally these
photos are coming
down the aisle of stalls closer to the
club room yes
and is the doorway that you see on the
left there the wash stall you just
mentioned yes
all right i'm going to draw your
attention now to s323
is this also a picture in that same
hallway with all the stalls yes
and what is uh what are
is this a picture
uh that would be a picture of the doors
of the two tack rooms
those are the two white doors on the
left
yes
and where does that hallway go to uh
into the club room
straight ahead
it looks like the
aisle sort of turns off to the left
there
yes where does that go
into the indoor riding arena
on basically the center of this photo
uh what are those wooden objects in the
center this would be
cubbies
and what are those used for
clients could store their personal items
in there
what are the big black um
metal objects in the middle of the
picture
window grates for the stalls of the
horses
now i'm showing you s-324
it looks like we can see those
stalls the stall doors that you just
talked out talked about in the bottom
right
and you just have to answer yes yes
that's the record thank you um
on the left are those more of those
lockers or cubbies that you discussed
yes
and those would be used by
clients
what is that white door straight ahead
where does that go
that would be the door leading to the
club room
how about the stairs on the right hand
side there
uh those leading that's leading to the
upstairs above the club room what was on
the upstairs part of the club room uh
storage mostly
okay
all right this is
s325
uh this is a closer up picture of the
door into the club room
and i'm sorry yes sorry yes that's all
right
uh
what are those pictures of on the right
hanging there
horses and competition
and are you familiar with who the
writers are in those three photos yes
who are they
uh michael
uh mary hoskins and myself
and are you the person that got cut off
on the top i
nice
am
uh
right then we're looking at s-326
uh
i believe this door was closed in a
prior picture yes that um
what is inside of that room
it's the saddles and bridles for the
horses
and what's that room called attack room
and it's s327 a photo inside of attack
room yes
that's s328 is that just the other side
of the same attacker yes
what is s329 a picture of
um it's the outside of the tack room
and what are all of these objects that
are hanging on the wall here next to the
attacker
um
they're
s
signify participation in uh
international horse competitions
and do you
do you know who had earned every single
one of
those right and i won't put you on the
spot to ask
i don't think i could say for certain
every single one
did you have any uh of those up there
yes and did the defendant michael
verizon yes
did mary haskins yes
and uh is it fair to say that there were
others for people who had trained at the
farm or been coached by michael yes
and this just for the sake of
completeness is s-330
a picture of that other door on the
other side of those awards yes
all right thank you mr hart
now with respect to uh the the club room
um was there an office on the opposite
side of the club room yes whose office
was that
michael's
is it fair to say that after being at
the property for the amount of time that
you were
you had been in that office before
i had
and were you aware that there was a safe
in that office
yes
who had primary access or control of
that safe
michael
were you aware of the combination to the
safe certain times i was
and then directing your attention
specifically to august of 2019
do you recall being in the safe at all
during that time period i do not
are you aware aware of whether or not uh
michael barissone had any firearms on
the property
i was can you tell the jury what your
understanding or knowledge of that was
uh there was a
firearm in the safe
do you recall what type of a firearm
it was a
somewhat long
small
gun
was it a handgun when you say a long
small gun was it a handgun or a rifle a
two-handed shotgun i suppose okay so
like a longer gun yeah
a shorter version of a longer gun got it
go ahead mr shellhorn
this is actually i'm going to move into
another topic here
i can keep going or if you want to take
the afternoon break
well why don't you go for another
seven minutes
get give or take
give or take a couple seconds seven
minutes
mr hardy during the the course of time
that you were living and working at that
farm in particular in new jersey
are you aware of whether or not the
defendant was ever married
yes
and did his wife at the time live at the
property
yes
are you aware
uh when that relationship was over
whether he had another relationship
yes and are you familiar with an
individual named mary haskins greg yes
were mary haskins gray and the defendant
involved in a romantic relationship yes
and do you know if they were also
involved in a business relationship
yes
did you know mary haskins gray before
she and the defendant started seeing
each other romantically i did
what was the nature of your relationship
with her
around the time when she and the
defendant started seeing each other
we were
friends but she lived far away so we
weren't close friends
and during the course of time that ms
gray and the defendant started seeing
each other
did she spend more more and more time at
the defendant's properties yes
did that
have any impact on your relationship
with her
we became closer
are you familiar with her having
children
yes and at times would her children
come to visit or stay at the farm for
periods of time yes
did
any so besides yourself
the defendant
either his ex ex-wife
or wife at the time or mary haskins gray
and the working students
did anyone ever live at that property
with any
regularity
sometimes students would come and stay
overnight
i think we already heard some of this
testimony so hopefully the jury will
forgive me but
with respect to running a farm a horse
farm are there a number of vendors that
come to the farm with the regular with
regularity yes who might some of those
vendors be
veterinarians for the horses
uh dentists for the horses
um farriers or blacksmiths for the
horses
um as well as uh delivery of
um horse feed and supplies
and it sounds like from the testimony
you've already given that most of the
clients or people who boarded horses
there did not live at the property
yes correct
were there any sort of gates or other
obstacles to someone driving onto the
property to get back to the barn
no
now when you and michael barissone were
at the farm together at the same time
how frequently would you communicate
frequently
and would that typically be face to face
if you were both there yes
at times did you discuss aspects of
running the farm or business related
topics
yes
did you also discuss things that were
going on in the equestrian world with
each other
yes
can you tell the jury a little bit about
how involved you were with running the
day-to-day operations at the farm and
i'm specifically talking about that
summer of 2019.
i was very involved
i would
take over almost everything on occasions
when michael would be away
but very involved in the day-to-day
are you familiar with the defendant
having a website to advertise the
business yes and what was the name of
the business
barristone dressage
judge i'd like permission
to show the witness s74 which i believe
has already been admitted into evidence
sure
mr hardin i'm showing you what's been
marked as s74 in evidence
uh
does this look like the generally the
the logo you were familiar with from the
website
yes
and do you see a date in the top left
corner of this of august 8 2019
yes
and moving down the uh
the page
who's that a picture of
me
and is that your name underneath the
picture
yes
and
was there then as we move a little bit
further down the page
uh some information about your writing
experience as well as some of the things
that you have to offer as part of the
business
yes
i'm going to show you one more
and this is s71 which has already been
admitted into evidence
is s71 also appear to be a
screenshot or
the website with the date of august 8th
2019 in the top left corner yes
and scrolling down
did this website or this page on the
website indicate that to inquire about
lessons or training an individual could
contact mr barrissone ms gray or
yourself
yes
now during the times that you worked
with michael barissone were you ever
ever able to observe anything about his
demeanor related to running the business
yes what would that be
um
certain happiness moments of happiness
or stress
um during different times of running the
business
and when you say that
i don't want to put words in your mouth
can you just elaborate on that a little
bit uh moments of stress versus moments
of happiness
um
happiness would be
himself or a student having probably a
particular success in the competition
or
improvements on the stables and stress
would be um you know students not doing
as well as they would like to or
horses being sick or injured
did he ever
have any stresses related to the
finances of running the business i'm
sure yes
can you tell the jury in your words what
safe sport is
it's a
organization that oversees
a lot of sports and sporting activities
mostly for conduct behavior
both bullying and
protecting minors in the sport
and is that something that
existed at the time that you first
became involved in equestrian or
dressage no
do you recall approximately if you
recall
when that came to be
approximately
2016.
is that something that you were required
to do anything to be licensed or
registered as a competitor you had to
complete yearly online training
classes
now are you aware
from
august 5th
2019
uh related to an individual named george
morris and a safe sport yes
do you know who george morris is yes can
you tell the jury who george morris is
um
one of the most famous american
um show jumping riders and coaches
and do you know if the defendant michael
barrisson knew george morris
he did
when safe sport uh
gave that punishment to him on august
5th of 2019 objection judge
your seven minutes is up
we're gonna break now when we
reformulate my question no well it's
it's since there's an objection rather
than keep the jury i'm going to dismiss
them
for their afternoon break and we can
continue all uh address mr um
blinkist objection
all right 15 minutes
thank you
you